bienvenue dans le off de tpm puis ici on
vous dévoile toutes les images les plus
drôles des coulisses on vous laisse
regarder
[Musique]
moi alors la chambre vide dans la maison
vide je passais mes nuits à 3 pour trois
répétitions par rapport à janis radio ni
jamais scène trois et demi par contre
elle est très bien habillé pour chanter
[Rires]
sur le côté latin fille la petite fille
isa la boîte est de lire la claque
ouais ouais ouais j'suis pas et regardez
ce maxi dennis dykes frotte à moi
j'avais comme un génie dérange tête
d'orange tout et plus tu te la manche
tutilescu tony parker
attention attention c'est pas la
chandeleur sionneau n'ai pas besoin moi
d'ampleur décalage ouais ça fait rien je
le confesse appelle-moi belgy l'odorant
ouais c'est tout pour l'oeuvre de tpm p
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine même
jour même heure ciao